bon ce trois polars avez vous retrouvé
qu'on est il de la situation sur place
après que les etats-unis ont appelé à la
désescalade
oui américain joe biden s'est entretenu
par téléphone avec pêle-mêle netanyahu
aujourd'hui disant qu'il souhaitait une
désescalade des violences aujourd'hui et
afin de mener vers un cessez le feu
suite à cet entretien benyamin
nétanyahou a dit apprécier le soutien
pour israël fait de remarques direct sur
le contenu de cet entretien il a dit que
la mission continuerait et qu'israël
était déterminé à continuer cette
opération jusqu'au retour de la paix et
de la sécurité pour tous des histoires
israélien tirs de roquettes israël
continue on était tous dernières heures
aujourd'hui 250 roquettes et tirs de
mortiers on ne s'appartient touché
israël dans le sud et le centre du pays
hamas a menacé de viser aujourd'hui tel
aviv
il ya eu des incendies aujourd'hui
désastre et liens ont été dressés dans
le même temps là israël où elle n'a plus
mais un communiqué fait rater fait
échouer trappe tentative d'intrusion du
hamas en israël via des tunnels du côté
palestinien le président palestinien
mahmoud abbas a appris la parole disant
que la situation actuelle était un
terrorisme étatique un crime de guerre
les ministères de la santé à gaza a
déclaré que depuis le big five à 227
palestine r1 perdu la vie soixante
quatre enfants se sont
mais dès les chiffres globaux vers gaza
ne peut plus rentrer à cause des
violences continues et les organisations
des militaires ont déclaré qu'elles sont
du mal à entrer sur le territoire
les frappes israéliennes continuent
ainsi que les tirs de roquettes
et puis hamas depuis gaza vers israël et
pour l'ajustement pourquoi israël est il
si déterminé à poursuivre l'opération à
gaza
souvent utilisé par les autorités
israéliennes ces nettoyages
il parle de nettoyer gaza ce que cela
signifie c'est qu'ils mènent vers des
frappes aériennes visant est selon eux
il n'est capacités militaires du hamas
il souhaite détruire autant d'armes
étant d'équipements militaires autant
devenu monsieur autant des ressources du
hamas qu'ils peuvent afin de réduire ses
capacités d'attac envers israël nous
avons entendu par exemple d'élégance le
ministre de la défense israélien dire
qu'israël a progressé beaucoup dans sa
recherche d
le premier ministre israélien a
également déclaré qu'il n'y avait pas de
calendrier vers une phase de l'opération
c'est également un sujet technique
intérieur il ya du soutien au sein
d'israël pour cette opération et emeline
et agneaux en profitent autant que
possible en encourageant l'opération et
en assurant aux israéliens qu'ils seront
en sécurité les autorités militaires
disent qui les évalue la situation et se
demandent quand il pourrait y avoir un
cessez le feu peut-être dans les jours à
venir
il y aura sans doute une flambée de
violence suivie par un cessez le feu
c'est ainsi que cela se passe en france
lorsqu'il ya en israël lorsqu'il ya des
conflits entre hamas et israël
merci beaucoup paula slayer journalistes
pour rt internationale en direct de tel
aviv ce soir